130 million light years from Earth a
galaxy called NGC for 993 two dead stars
trapped in a rapidly diminishing spiral
[Music]
it's like listening to the ringing of
the cosmos itself the sound of that
collision if you will
imprinted on the fabric of space and
time itself Livingston Louisiana the
advanced LIGO Observatory its mission to
detect gravitational waves generated in
space gravitational wave is a distortion
of space-time that's caused by usually
some kind of very traumatic
gravitational event events such as
supernovas or the collision of black
holes were massive stars
[Music]
2015 LIGO makes history by detecting
gravitational waves for the first time
100 years after Einstein's prediction
it's the signature of the crash of black
holes it's almost like listening to the
sound of a distant car crash that you
didn't witness but you're so clever and
the sound of this car crash is such a
unique signature that you are able to
use your computers to model exactly the
type of cars that must have collided
together then in 2017
LIGO picks up a different kind of signal
the unfolding of the August 2017 event
was nothing short of extraordinary so
the signal comes in and a signal is
strange it has a long lasting signal
there's over a hundred seconds less than
two seconds later a gamma-ray telescope
detected a flash of gamma rays from that
same part of the sky and very quickly
the world's astronomers know that
something is happening something's up
it's new and is different
[Music]
this combination of a long gravitational
wave signal and a blaze of gamma rays
acts as a beacon for astronomers when
they saw this event they sent out a
worldwide alert to astronomers across
the globe saying hey we saw something
interesting and it came from a
particular patch of sky then all the
chatter started amongst the astronomical
community and everyone's starting
pointing their telescopes at this one
part of the sky within hours thousands
of astronomers and physicists across the
globe are frantically collecting data on
this mysterious event
there's not just the gravitational ways
there's not just the gamma rays
there's the visible life there's
infrared light there's ultraviolet light
and all these signals together tell us a
story and this was the very first time
we've seen these two multiple messengers
at once gravitational waves and regular
light so that was a groundbreaking
moment for astronomy scientists realize
this isn't another black hole collision
this is something different when you see
an explosion in the universe there
aren't exactly a lot of candidates
there's not a lot of things in the
universe that blow up but the length of
the signal is the smoking gun the
collision of two black holes was quick
this one was the longer slower death in
spiral of two neutron stars by ruling in
closer and closer speeding up and then
when they finally collide when they
finally touch releasing a tremendous
amount of energy into the surrounding
system
the collision throws up huge clouds of
matter which may have slowed down the
light very slightly the light and
gravitational waves travel for 130
million years arriving at Earth almost
simultaneously it's the first time
astronomers see neutron stars collide
they call it the Killa Nova and this
spectacular cosmic event doesn't just
release energy the aftermath of this
neutron star collision this Killa Nova
created a tremendous amount of debris
which blasted out into space and this
may finally have provided us the
evidence of where some very special
heavy elements are created through the
destruction of a neutron star comes the
seeds for the essential ingredients of
life itself
we breathe oxygen molecules o to water
is hydrogen and oxygen most of our body
is made up of carbon compounds that
include nitrogen phosphorus one of the
big questions in science over the
history of humanity has been what are
the origins of these elements and it
turns out that neutron stars play a
critical role in creating many of the
heavy elements
most of the elements on earth are made
in stars but how the heaviest elements
are made has been one of Sciences
longest-running mysteries for a long
time we knew there was a problem with
making these heavier atoms things like
gold and platinum you know all the way
out towards uranium and really the most
energetic thing we had in the universe
was supernova explosions so they had to
be created somehow in supernovas but
when scientists ran computer simulations
virtual supernovas failed to forge these
oversized atoms in 2016 astronomer IDO
Berger explained a potential solution to
the mystery if you open any one of these
books and flip to the page that tells
you where gold came from it will tell
you that gold came from supernova
explosions
but it was becoming clear the textbooks
were out-of-date the forum heavy
elements requires a lot of neutrons and
so another possible theory was that the
heaviest element were produced in the
mergers of two neutron stars in a binary
system but at the time no one had
actually seen a neutron star collision
it was difficult to convince the
community that this was a potential
channel for the production of heavy
elements the proof is to actually see
this process happening in the universe
the 2017 Killa Nova provides the perfect
opportunity it generates thousands of
hours of data scientists notice pattern
subtle changes in the color of the Killa
Nova remnants in space when you have an
event that is very bright it emits a
certain amount of light and it emits it
at certain wavelengths what we think of
as colors different colors in a
pyrotechnics display indicate the use of
different chemicals and fireworks in the
same way scientists can uncover the
elements in the Killa Nova by the colors
in the explosion
as the killing over turns red they
realize it's the results of newly
created heavy elements starting to
absorb blue light as we watched this
remnant change the explosion change in
color expand and cool we could estimate
what sort of elements were being
produced the light from the debris
shifts from blue and violet to red and
infrared the color change provides clues
about the presence of certain heavy
metals
well this neutron star collision this
Killa Nova produced brightness and a
color spectrum that are consistent with
models of predictions that produce gold
and platinum this model is called the
art process short for rapid Neutron
capture that is a bit of a complicated
term that describes how we make atoms
heavier than iron you need a really
Neutron rich environment and as you
might imagine a neutron star collision
is a very Neutron rich environment if
these models are correct and this blows
me away this collision this Killa Nova
produced several dozen times the mass of
the earth in just gold
the 2017 Killa Nova not only reveals the
origin of key elements it sheds light on
the neutron stars interior the strongest
material in the universe creating a
magnetic field a trillion times greater
than that of Earth